[Music]
the idea of slow down your design
started with a small
catering with my friends in viennese
cafe where we were talking about the
current issues like you always do we
discuss because we are like a colorful
bunch of people who study political
science echo design math and everything
and then we're always interested in the
world politics and there were these
fires in amazon and we were like oh the
earth is crying we need to do something
we need to start to reuse things to make
this society think greener and that was
our main
idea and the target group was of course
in our peer groups young people of
vienna
[Music]
me and my project team had various
skills that we could use and my skill in
that moment was that i was into
solidarity projects from the formal side
how to write your solidarity project
dina was or is still
the green do-it-yourself part because
she's a vegan she likes creative stuff
[Music]
had already or did already some products
on their own so management skills and of
course people skills networking matthias
studied environmental studies in the
area of finances so it was also a little
bit an expertise that we needed at that
moment
[Music]